the person I'm going to talk about today
his name is Henry class Bryan my
conscious doesn't allow me to
mispronounce our meetings I'm just gonna
type his name so this would be his and a
lot of times it's it's a degenerative
kasparian so maybe you've seen his name
tell like this and he he was not a
strong player he was only an
international master but what he was
known for is his composition in his
chess game and game studies and he's
published several books and they're and
they're really great books so he was
born in Tbilisi in 1910 and just like
the grandpa version has also offered me
in descent but he was also born in
Tbilisi and he was ten time Armenian
champion but this was back when Armenia
wasn't the chess powerhouse than it is
now but he also but he tied for first
several times with big rampant was young
so he was he was a good player but not
one of the strongest players when we
think of those times think of strong
players we don't really think of him and
I don't know if anyone has ever solved
chess from just studies but they're very
different than regular tactics than we
do and they really require creativity
and not the kind of creative creativity
that if you saw like today's game like
Carlton versus Carl and I like that kind
of creativity is the kind of creative
creativity that really you have to think
very differently and a lot of times you
have to come up with stalemate or you
have to come up with this really kind of
ideas that don't really happen in the
game but I would suggest doing those
kind of puzzles because they really make
you think and just really make you think
in a way that usually wouldn't and I
would say in Armenia he's he's at least
among chess players is just as well
known as Tigran Petrosian it was in
Armenia we have Chet house chess house
or house of chess named after Petrosian
and of course Petrosian is such a big
legend in Armenia and you know chess in
Armenia is what it is today because of
him essentially because of you know if
we can world champion and it just became
so popular in Armenia but so we have the
chess house in Armenia all all chess
players are familiar with it so it's a
three-story building it's a very nice
building and actually Petrosian
literally lay the foundation because he
like laid the first stone of that
building when they're building it and
next to it is also the chess school
which is not named after Kasparian and
that's where all the kids go to learn
chess that's where I first started
learning chess and Veronica piano also
teaches here a lot that's why he also
started learning chess and aronia and
all this strong players that's why you
know sorry the chess school and then you
move on then you play at the chess when
you're stronger you play at the chess
house and like he has you know he is
very well known come composer and he's
puzzles I'm gonna go over his puzzles
and some of them they're very
complicated and they really require you
to think in ways you usually wouldn't
and but I think just for even just
looking at the solution and even
thinking about those puzzles I think
it's just interesting and some of them
are very fascinating and I like it
another person that I lose puzzles I
like is what of them it also has like
very nice composition but I mean even if
you can't solve them even if you just
look at them and the ideas that come up
they're really fascinating so I'm going
to okay so I'm going to start with this
one so I'm gonna leave it up for a
little bit let's see if anyone can come
up with something and then if not then
I'll just show the solution so why to
move it's very interesting because the
way you approach this kind of position
is completely different how you would
approach a chess game first all you
would not get position like this in a
chess game so how to even think about
this position so the black king is not
in such a great position what about
white rook yeah white's rule is
trapped essentially no yeah see I told
you after recording for this to happen
okay so so Brett what's the first of all
we want to look at in this position
really I think that first of all you
want to take the rope right
okay so 91 so what happens Kings what
can I just run away to be five
but okay so whether we're up to
something right okay so 91 so let's make
this move so 91 so of course if the King
runs away I'm just gonna take a free
night but so what happens if I just say
so I think the most natural move is
first to take because you know you have
two pieces under attack so you want to
exchange one and then run away but here
you have to worry about this pawn moving
so let's say if I play something like
this okay not there maybe let's say I
play something like this and then you
protect this pawn now I might get a
queen so you have to be careful and also
if we exchange all the paths then I can
make a drop so we found this 91 move
b5 and then I take it but then I'll take
with the pump
okay so King before so this is the move
right okay so now our goal is not to
sell me this king but the king is okay
but look the difference is now he
doesn't have the b5 square anymore
because there's a pawn here so now we're
trying not to still meet the king but
the King is completely boxed so this is
what I mean like this is kind this is
kind of thing would never happen in your
game but it's just so interesting to
kind of come up with this kind of ideas
I mean like you can always make a draw
so now we're trying to find a win
I mean yeah I'm here right so now we
have to somehow do it I mean we're not
really looking at it from practical game
point of view because in a practical
game first of all you don't get this
position secular well okay if you need
to make a try you can just make it wrong
and this is actually no even in a
practical game let's say you're
attacking your opponent and you see you
have a perpetual so now you can think
there for 30 minutes and try to find
something if you don't find something
you take the perpetual so here you don't
find something make a drum so how can we
not still meet the king so so here's
next move is gonna be d6 and then he has
no move so we have to do that that he
can move so he cannot move any pieces
you cannot move through any pieces on
like this pieces cannot move so the only
we have to make it so that D pawn can
move yeah if you play the six and stole
me so how can we do it so after this is
the D funk and move again so you have to
give up your night where can your five
king c5 King you're letting my king of
the whole point is your box mighty box
my king and you have to checkmate it
exactly 94 so now he has a move so here
and check
okay so let's go back and this is the
kind of things he did like he just sat
there and he came up with this puzzles
yeah which I think it's amazing
okay so King before d6 okay
so this one is more straightforward so
the same kind of motif but now you
cannot move your night because my king
will run away in the other position the
king was just blocked in king the tree
if I could be 5
King where king t3 now oh then my king
will run away once I go before my rook
is protected so the same kind of
checkmate with it but different so how
can we so the how can we bug the King
anyone more take the rook the king see
for now the king is blocked okay so we
can't tell me mate in three so b5 only
move
I captured so the same kind of checkmate
actually I like the other two I think
the other checkmate is even nicer after
um yeah I think this one is nicer
because there's also a rock on the board
all right let's do okay this one is one
of my favourite puzzles so again white
to move again something that would never
happen in your game you will never have
a bishop one-eight-seven upon on g6 so
now you have Celsius if I playing for a
win or a draw draw because you have a
very useless Bishop when I have a pond
it's gonna be queen in five moves okay
so you cannot get the pawn you cannot
get a queen of your own your bishop is
completely useless so what's your other
hope of trying yeah then I'll capture it
and I have no vision you know anyone
ever useless Bishop what London King
takes
can gauge it so what's your other hope
of not losing this game I was talking
about this in my first class soulmate so
to get a stalemate not but yeah in
tennis tell me do you have to first of
all you have to get rid of your bishop
second of all you have to do something
with this age fun because it's pawn
moves and then figure out where do you
need your King to be so you have to be
very accurate and you have to put all
these ideas together so we know how
we're gonna get rid of our bishop so
whenever play Bishop Jade I have to take
otherwise you'll take my c4 pawn and
then I can get a queen so you know how
to get rid of your bishop second you
have to figure out how to get rid of
that or what to do with that h1
right okay so now we have all this side
so when I would kind of have a vision of
how the stalemates gonna work so next we
wanted a next you want to be accurate so
it still involves some kind of
calculation which is the useful thing of
doing this puzzle so your calculation
has to be very accurate
so what's going to be our first move h5
Bishop do you see the problem with
Bishop g8 is I'm gonna take and then
when you push h5 h6 I may take that guy
- Oh put it alive it is together so h5
h6 here now I cannot take because now
you're just in time so I have to ignore
so Bishop Jade now you want to take my
pawn and stop me so I have to take so I
have to go to h8 now I mean still mate
so King G - kinky - and if you get a
queen it's Stallman if you get a bishop
actually you cannot win with this Bishop
because your king is installment and you
have no way of getting out of this tell
me so even if I lose this f2 pawn you
still have no way of winning I mean I
don't have to lose my phone I can just
protect it yeah that's not next so even
if I give up this pawn you have no way
of winning because you cannot promote
took when you cannot get out of stomach
you can promote to a pawn but the
problem is and now again you don't have
a move if you take it's still meat if
you don't take you play Knight b3 then
I'm gonna take and then play here again
you're playing without a king so
eventually you'll run out of moves and
again you run out of moves but your
first few moves they have to be very
accurate because are you if you your
first moves are not accurate and this is
not gonna happen if you start with
Bishop g8 let's say that I'm gonna take
now I'm gonna take this guy - and now I
have a lot of moves to waste
now I don't have to get a queen and
still meet you can just push my pawn and
now I'm gonna get a queen with a check I
can capture this pawn so I have a lot of
moves to waste but in the original
position the original move order I did
not have all this options very nice okay
okay this is another one I really like
so white to move
and then when you start doing a lot of
this puzzle just kind of started
noticing the patterns so your point is
trying to get a quick but what's the
problem for block he's King
all right so Bishop h2 kind of a natural
move to look good because Bishop h2 when
you play what happens if I go can give
to ya it spins I'm not if I play if I
play King you have time no longer
threatening to get a queen so you can
just take my pawn and then you can give
up this rook for a pawn because you get
to keep extra Bishop so so I have to
poke engage for so if you were to just
now you have to kind of like have a
visualizes checkmate in your head if you
were to checkmate this king where do you
need your pieces to be right so you have
to push the pawn on g3 which means you
have to protect each h3 square right so
how are you gonna do that
but so first of all I'm trying to get a
queen with a check but even forget that
for a second so where do you need you
need which piece so you need to get the
owned on h2 which means you have to move
the bishop out of the white okay so that
we know what another thing you have to
look out for so I want to get a queen
with a check so we're not sure if it's
relevant or not and another thing I want
to do is I want to take this G to pawn
which means you're not going to be able
to play g3 so how do we stop that
so how do we stop the eff takes you to
move no but then you're not gonna have
your chicken right so you have to give
up your rook okay so now we have again
we have to be very accurate so now we
have to be very accurate where we put
our bishop
so you have a lot of squares but not all
of them work so think about what your
opponents
what is your opponent's gonna do after
he gets a after I get a queen and you go
King edge - so you're trying to
checkmate me so how can i I have to make
an escape path for my King right so
what's gonna be my next move now for
block yeah so I move my bishop you get a
queen I play King gauge - now you're
threatening to three mate so I have to
why right because your opponent wants to
play GG for so the King can run away
so Bishop c7 so if you go g4 because if
you play it all the way to be eight so
it's relevant this these positions are
very tricky so if you played here now g4
and you don't have a mate I'm just gonna
run away now you lost all your pieces
right so Bishop see sound only move
exclamation good so now what is blacks
only move
g4 gets made it what's the only way to
stop the second mate so
right so we have to pin the punch so
okay so what did it know look if you
move the bishop from this diagonal I
mean you just loosened and I'm gonna
check you and then now you're not even
threatening mate you know I'm gonna play
here my Kings gonna run away so Bishop
this is very accurate move again if no
your opponent has two options you play
g6 and get made it move the Queen if the
Regents look the one so it doesn't have
a move either move keep the Queen Queen
on the second rank so it's gonna get
made it from here or or play here right
so we don't want to get greedy
so g3 and another checkmate all right so
vitamin
what
yesin calculator you can't just tell me
more that's a good idea
so now we have to find huh he's trying
to still made himself it wants to put
his king I wants to put his king on a
five push people V 6 P 5 P 4 a 4 and
then is install me okay so now now when
I get a queen I protect
I told you you're not gonna win well we
can't stop like from playing music what
sort of thing is to go there you go
that's a good way of thinking right if
you're trying to come up like you have
this idea and you're trying to create
this position and then you see like you
want to make sure you're starting it
accurately and so if you don't want your
opponent to be able to play Bishop then
you can start with this okay so b6 okay
so just like this okay so b6 I should
not be six year behind you're right
a one two three four five Oh a right one
two three four okay hold on let me sit
down okay so yeah so your idea is right
so here here and it's actually funny
because you're not install media you
need to move so Stallman yourself
but then if your opponent comes and
tries to take your pawns then if you
think this phone is already still made
no I mean I think this is just a like a
really funny position because here's a
queen and you need two moves to
stalemate yourself there's nothing like
to move there's nothing productive we
can do to stop this tell me okay so let
me see so the king disowned you saying
t6 okay so let me count oh yeah now I'm
in the square yeah and if you play b6
here now you can you're gonna love it
yeah yeah because I get a check yeah all
right
yeah b6 oh yeah why not think if I start
with this examine what's behind so
you're right okay okay this yeah this is
another one of my favorites so it helps
to do a summary of the position I think
that always helps in an in position
because when first you look at the
position you have no idea what's going
on but once you break it down maybe it's
still complicated it's still not easy
but at least you get some kind of a
grasp it's always nice to summarize a
position and it's actually very good
thing to do during your games especially
when a lot of things happen when the
nature of the position changes let's say
you're attacking and then a lot of
exchanges happen you really want to stop
and like reevaluate and do somewhere and
see what changed because if you're still
in the attacking mode and then you don't
have an attack you're still pushing and
then all of a sudden you see on now I
have weaknesses my positions bad so you
know it's always good to see what's
going on so you're down a rope so it's
an important thing to keep in mind
because you have to understand if you're
down the rope and your opponent maybe
doesn't mind giving the rook back so if
your whole purpose to get the rope back
then you might not miss your win but you
have this t7 pawn so so you also have a
knight on h8 that's trapped and this f7
Knight is stopping your pants and
queening so I mean and the king is in a
little bit of
you know not comfortable position yeah
because okay
the problem is when I play rook c8 and
you go King eight seven and I take on f7
and you take on d7 what's gonna happen
again I told you ready I'm up a rope I'm
gonna give my route back so you're so
fast and giving your answer take a pause
and thing right you 595 number maybe six
on my rope
okay so rook c8 so just take a pause on
that position that's made in wonder
Roxy 1887 night f7 so what is the meat
does I want to see to me right yeah so
rook c8
so if then rook c8 what's gonna be your
opponent's move so we're searching it's
downloaded so what's the other this is
you have to come move by move see like
you want to calculate very fast but it's
better to calculate accurately then you
know I can't land quickly so ropes so 98
next move so 98 gives your opponent some
so first of all okay so when I play rook
c8 and then you play king gage seven so
the problem is there's one move threat
and the rookie's a threat if you take
there's the mate and I want to Quinn so
what 98 does is now you have a rook in
front of your pawn and so of course you
have to take so now it was blocked move
blocks move what would block to just to
make it make it a try and not even think
about it
right I'll take your pond I'll take your
knife so this is why it's important to
keep count of the material because you
if your opponent's off a lot of material
your point can give away a lot of
material so I'll keep my boy my rook
I'll take your night and I'm up upon in
an end game so now you have to make a
drum okay so how to continue from here
it's white
No
what
hold on IG six what happens if I take
the night but then I have to look for a
queen I'm happy with my Turks so okay so
we have to move the night out of the way
because if we simply move the rook yeah
because our opponent has a threat so we
have to move that guy
so 96 so what's the other move Knight up
seven
take what
okay so you want to play Knight f7 okay
so rook takes so ecigs
okay so I'll go rook g7
yeah but the problem that your king is a
problem Sanger okay one no I'm gonna
check with you yeah then I'll get cool
two queens for because I want to take on
the zone and take your neck so I can
play a rock a one
yeah but then I can I mean worse again
we're gonna get the Queen versus two
rooks position
I mean native sound has a very subtle
idiom so night at 7:00 so rook takes so
the rook on f7 is a force because when
I'm uh looks broke somewhere and you
take on d7 what can I do when um rooks
on T sound and f7 what can i do ecig
support your looks but the question is
where you're gonna put your rook because
okay so let me show you so knight of
seven so it take so if you move let's
say your rook on c8 I think I have to
take your phone and then you go east six
and the problem is if you take one of my
rooks I don't have a way of stopping
your part from Queen ik what defensive
resource does your opponent have and
this is the sneaky board
so where can I move my roof so let's say
I want to play rook c8 as a question
mark so route this I 1 is 6 so let's
save this position
rugby rugby ain't very nice very nice
resource and it's funny because you
cannot play rook f8 because when I take
I protected my rook but rook t8
attacking my rook so when you have
several pieces you know even in a game
when you have two pieces under attack if
you can move one of them and attack your
opponent's piece then you're gonna save
it so if you take and again now now plug
I mean white like it's the one playing
for win
so where should we move our rook in this
position
oh no sorry Chauncey rookie it exactly
so it cannot be attached so when you
take now I'm gonna play six and if you
play rock the eight again I protected my
rock if you play recap paint this is
what I mean this rookie ideas so it's
very sneaky yeah so Rock th is the line
and it takes f7 I'm still win okay let
me see which one the next one what Oh
oh yeah this is another way to move
yeah it's a crazy position and obviously
someone
yoky I'm not gonna move somewhere random
first of all I'm not gonna move
somewhere random your opponent also has
saving resources what if I play Queen g8
okay then Quinn defy perpetual so you're
making moves like come up with an idea
think of your opponent's resources think
about what you're going to do like how
you're gonna win this position okay
first of all I think first move is
obvious but so see something's gonna
happen when you play so why did I put my
queen on a che if it was blocked uma
what would block through here and
specially implement and the problem is
with Roxy Wan when I play that showed
the move if I play Quinn a one you take
now I'm gonna take your work and I stop
the Queen so now I have this Queen a one
threat I'm gonna start checking you
so here I want to get rid of my queen so
if I'm if I don't have a queen so
stalemate for what so how do we stop
Queen a one route before
so now Queen g8
now if I get rid of my queen it's a drum
so if you play King v5 I'll happily play
Quincy for
same thing I'm gonna get from v5 okay I
really okay
so again to show this I'm gonna check
you you play here I'm gonna check you if
you take this Queen it's a draw so I'm
very happy to get rid of it so you have
to basically stop blood my queen
so my queen cannot move off the back
rank without a check so if you play here
I cannot take because I get made it so
you can still have to block my Queens if
Queen h8 the rookie five Queen here
b6 because if I take with the pawn d7
and then you get a queen and check me
so now I don't have Queen g8 anymore
so what so now how you're gonna win this
position this is a question because we
can go back and forth forever so how did
how can you possibly check meet my king
where do you need your rook okay so you
need it on the a file that works you too
so let's say I play here
brookey to let me say rocket
but they need to get a queen so let me
see what's the matter what's the problem
with Queenie - I mean so wait what did
you wanna do yeah
so here mating - so it takes and now
check me alright so let's do last one
let me see which one I want to do cuz I
have several I'm looking through them I
think I actually have only one more left
this one is a little complicated but
this is another one I like because it
ends up in a rook end game that's like a
well known position
so again wait to move
so again it's a good idea to kind of you
know go over what's going on in the
position
right so Oh
so both sides have a passed pawn so why
can't you push your pawn right now
you're pinned so you need to get moving
Rick
so root case I'm on temple move you're
moving and the problem is you cannot go
just anywhere because I'll take your
pawn sir okay seven you're threatening
mate so f3 and rock g6 so now I want to
push her pawn right b7 so so what
happens if let's say he plays repeat how
do we win this engage
be it I'll take this rook don't this is
not this is not a fancy thing it's just
rock anything to win
so just rookie right yeah and then you
check and then here
so unfortunately he's a move behind so
now he has to come up with an idea of
his own so so let's see if you can come
up with an idea for block the block was
how can block how it can block from what
his own phone okay so rook G 2 and F 2
now I want to promote with a check rook
we're broke up seven the beautiful move
can I take with the rook I Quinn with a
check and I take with the King because
it's a discovery check
so what to do
so
and then if I take a look
no then I get a Quinn
so stop my palm from so I have a thread
I want to take your rook and get a queen
so how do you stop my pawn from quitting
okay so Mike the thing is my king is
very close so I can very easily for
example if you take my rook I'll take
yours you take my punt and I'm gonna run
and take your pawn
and the reason is it dries because my a
Simon rook is in a horrible position
it's a very bad place for rook to be
because it's very inactive so when you
put your rope behind it even in front of
it and I can do anything so okay so what
is black going to do right otherwise I'm
going so I can get seven take here you
don't get to make some moves
it's black to move of course it was
white some of you take my own so how
does black defend okay who can't see
until the end actually from here we can
do that so black is one defensive
resource can get to and then okay yeah
and the reason I love this this study so
much is because you end up in a well
known theoretical position so rook Jiwon
would be 1 and now skewer you take on p7
and the funny thing is if white does
anything else then it's a dead drop
because I'm gonna play King g7 and
another one well not there a composition
so after all this craziness we just end
up in this well-known endgame that just
went for white ok so this is all I have
so I would suggest you he has several
books so if you like to studies and I
think they're really fascinating and
they really get your creativity going so
you can check out his puzzles